this is the most here comes the wave ah
there it is yeah this is Hertz
hey what's going on everybody from first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today I'm joined by Henry Rollins he's a
punk rock icon radio host columnist and
all-around Renaissance man but can t
handle the wings of death we'll find out
today Henry welcome to the show thank
you how are you with hot food I don't
need it
you don't you're not a spicy food I
can't handle it okay so not a hot food
person well with that said are you ready
to get it going no no not at all
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it was good you like that one sure we're
making you into a wind guy Henry no I'll
be your wingman so it seems like when
people are looking for travel
inspiration maybe they'll Google best
beaches but with you it seems like you
look at the front page of the newspaper
figure out which country is most [ __ ]
up at the time and then you head there
yeah in your travels when were you most
scared for your life in America yeah in
California specifically California is
the place where I've nearly died a
couple of times like that you know
really unfun stories of like real real
near-death the rest of the time besides
I was at um I was in Baghdad two mortars
landed near a building I was in which
was fortified I was in no danger the
concussion was such that it literally
felt like a fist a ghost punch going
into your solar plexus was the
concussion is it incredibly powerful on
the streets of Cairo if you leave the
hotel neighborhood and kind of go into
the the neighborhoods you'll get some
intense stares and I've been there a few
times and every single time I've gotten
that that I'm not faring very well and I
mean why I'm kind of like wanted to go
home which country made you most hopeful
for the future of civilization wow
that's a great question hmm
walking the streets of Tehran and having
people stop me with perfect English like
why are you here where are you from I'm
from America Wow you're here alone yeah
why so I've always wanted to come to
Iran thank you for coming here please
don't kill us where you see that they
want the future I go what about your
government that I get what about your
come on yeah I know where all the sudden
you have things in common and so I have
found in a lot of my travels a lot of
hopefulness where you find a lot of
people are um
they want what you want you know clean
water a day without conflict basically a
fistful of 50s in a day without fear as
they say so you're like a wings veteran
you sit across from some sweating guests
I mean some white belt hot food person
right but you're like Bruce Lee and
Enter the Dragon you're like this up and
you're like slappy these bottles the
only fight I can win is with wings all
right so you're obviously in phenomenal
shape and I know the credit strength
training is helping build your sense of
self-worth as a teenager but I know that
no one can spend as much time in the
weight room as you've spent in the
weight room without picking up some Jim
pet peeves along the way what are the
gym shenanigans that bother you the most
people who sit on a piece of equipment
that you want to use but they're not
moving your eyes they're texting or on
their cell phone people who talk to
someone else
near you like someone's on a treadmill
may their elbow on something that's not
moving and they're like yeah so and then
I said I'm really I'm trying to focus
here so I'm gonna be on this damn thing
for an hour and my body wants to go home
right now when I still have 55 minutes
to go so March you shut up and so
basically not being able to get a sense
of concentration or rhythm going because
people are using this as like the
hangout hour as if they're going to get
in shape by looking at the equipment you
actually have to apply yourself
[Music]
good so the internet seems especially
fascinated with Henry Rollins quotes and
I think it's the intensity of your
worldview that people find appealing so
what I want to do is give you some other
quotes from other no [ __ ] given icons
and I just wonder how they hit your ear
I just want to hear your reaction does
that sound good
yeah friends come and go but banners
hang forever
that's from Kobe Bryant boy what a deep
and pithy thing for someone to say my
god I'm gonna get a chisel and whack
that into my forearm so whether that's
the parking garage
do you think it's all a little
sociopathic or what do you think I think
Kobe Bryant was a tremendous athlete and
I think to play sports on that level it
just must be like this a beyond anything
I can comprehend obsession to be a
champion in such an amazing sport and to
be a champion in that sport I think you
get to say anything you want a man who
have used the world the same at 50 as he
did at 20 has wasted 30 years of his
life that's from Muhammad Ali I love
that I don't think about things the same
way as I do in all 20 I'd like to think
that um I have pulled my head out of
that dark place a little bit and I'm
perhaps more patient and less judgmental
as a man who's pushing 60 I'll be closer
to 60 walking out of this with this
champ
my greatest pain in life is that I will
never be able to see myself perform live
that's from Kanye West
[Music]
[Music]
all right so here at first we feast were
obsessed with our guests food obsession
so I have to ask you about yours what
can you tell me about old Dutch white
cheddar popcorn because I hear you
described it it sounds like crack in a
bag when I have my tour bus my Bon Jovi
mobile when we are in the American
Midwest every single day we go to local
grocery stores and Walmart's and we get
every bag we can and we come back to
California with literally massive
t-shirt boxes full of popcorn we're
talking like 40 some bags which I can
get through before the Christmas break
is over
don't call him he's eaten and so that's
how Christmas break is for me cheese
popcorn all right Henry so every current
segment on our show called explain that
Graham we do a deep dive and I guess
Instagram and pull interesting pictures
but with you Henry we've done a little
bit of a twist we've pulled some great
Henry Rollins throwbacks so what I'll do
is I'll show you the picture and then
you can tell me if there's a story
reminds you of what was going on in your
life or career at the time does that
sound good yes this is like where you'd
lead the dog back to where it's soiled
the carpet and you go was that you yes
that's what's happening we were digging
it all up first things first
best dressed guy at the 37th annual home
that's 22 years ago here's my
explanation I was up for two Grammys at
that particular Grammy and so I ran over
with my performers laminate and my
clothes I could just get sweated out and
they said and the Grammy for Best spoken
book on tape or whatever it is
goes to Henry Rollins I'm like here I go
so I go running at the stage it's
security they don't no one knows who I
am so I go running up to the stage and
it was like do we let them up here and
these guys kind of well Dwight do i
armbar him I think what
go up go on and so I ran up there and
they have one that's blank see just
holding up and everyone's like look who
is this guy right the few who recognize
me when I thought he'd be taller and so
I'm holding up the Grammy I said it must
be really strange for people who look
like you to be looking at a guy who
looks like me holding something like
this you know what kind of it yeah and I
said thanks and I put it down and and
they led me away and I did the entire
press and you do looking like that I
love this picture yeah Santa Monica
Civic 1983 I think I learned a powerful
lesson at that show don't go too close
to the audience there's like 3,500
people it's different than them there's
like 300 people or I know yeah they look
you in the eye with that many people
that people just get nutty and like my
face was grabbed my hair was grabbed I
was like being held because of my hair
and he was ripping it out like they
don't even know what they're doing
and so I kind of learned a lesson about
the crowd mentalities and hell when
there's a lot of people one person will
do something stupid and then all of a
sudden everyone's doing something that
stupid thing you and Ozzy Beck's
each January 1996 yeah yeah yeah yeah I
told my bandmates when we're on stage
opening for Ozzy if you see a red dot on
your shirt that's a sniper because they
only want to see us they don't want to
see any opening band I want you to
finish the show so run in an evasive
zig-zag pattern
avoid the dot but keep playing if these
one tooth Ozzie fans come over the
barricade with axes brickbats or mobile
meth labs run run run but keep playing
as long as you can until the cord gets
disengaged from your gear actually
Ozzy's audience was very very nice to us
for 45 minutes between songs all here's
Dan when I Queen it Wembley and then
Aussie goes on
two hours later so I'm here
[Applause]
is the sound of 19,000 people all going
like that how many more minutes with
Rollins in this song and that's and that
was the start of my friendship with Ozzy
Osbourne who's one of my favorite human
beings in the world he's one of the
nicest most honest people I've ever met
he's such not a letdown so I've been a
fan of his since I was like 12 or 13 and
he's just uh he's just one of my
favorite people I flew on the private
jet that night I drank a Diet Pepsi with
OCD told me the story of how they wrote
paranoid
in the studio it's great aggressive
branding very aggressive brand name out
of Vermont really cuz that's the last
place you think in Ben and Jerry and
Bernie and dirty dicks I'll let you say
[Music]
you're very prolific in your own right
but outside of that you're also an
insatiable reader listener a consumer so
here's that one and know if you had to
recommend one album one film and one
book for the National Curriculum what
would they be
wow that's a great question
one book I would recommend the fiery
trial by Eric Foner fo NER it's a book
about Lincoln's conflicts and his
evolution of his thinking about slavery
and emancipation and politics during the
Civil War Eric Foner is an amazing
historian I think the Civil War is his
wheelhouse it's just the best book I've
ever read on Lincoln and it's just an
amazing read I think a record that
should be given to everyone upon birth
you come kneel falling out of the canal
whap as I did on some unnamed Street in
Washington in 61 I would give America
raw power by the Stooges my
second-favorite Stooges album the first
would be my first my favorite album in
the whole world is funhouse the Stooges
second amma but the third album i think
is america's greatest contribution to
the hard rock
if we have a hat to throw in the hard
rock ring up against the stones in
Zeppelin and deep purple etc etc it
would be raw power by the Stooges that's
where America says we got game it's raw
power and then one film Apocalypse Now
because it's quotable and it's so much
about war that it's not about war it's
about insanity and the insanity of war
and the politics that we're by the time
you get deep in it's not about war
anymore and everyone's like really this
is just nuts we should all go home
and I think we should reach those
decisions sooner like before we went
into Iraq we should have gone into the
future what this won't end well screw it
let's get some wins you ever done a
zombie thing will you run around black
vomit coming out of your mouth come back
can't say I have any of you what a day
in the life what you think I was
rehearsing vintage toured t-shirts have
become one of the more prevailing
fashion trends and recent or expensive
and I'm not sure if irony is the right
word but bands like Nirvana and The
Ramones and Black Flag really see the
celebrity red carpet go twos and I
wonder what you think when you see
Barney's for example releasing a Black
Flag shirt made of Japanese cashmere
cotton with a $265 price point is that
validating do you roll your eyes how do
you unpackage that sort of thing is that
a mindfuck to me it's what society does
eventually in black flag is basic accor
pert Loco Pepsi IBM the Black Flag logo
which was we tried to do and we would
send the promoters here's the logo
here's the lettering use this the logo
the logo the logo and so we were just
trying to make that where you could see
it in the dark and if you do that long
enough it's not yours anymore it becomes
a folktale it becomes it belongs to the
the the Macy's of the world and
eventually someone will put it on the
back of a $5,000
motorcycle jacket even black flag and
Nirvana and all of these things become
not exactly corporatized but they become
part of the speak they become part of
the lexicon of what's in the the kind of
our social in and almost anything that
stands around long enough gets absorbed
it's it's stinging yeah I feel okay yes
what's what is that what's a bomb
mmm-hmm it's a real bomb without my
specs on yeah speaking of logos yeah
yeah good you enjoy that one well it's
so hot that you can't really taste any
flavor mm-hmm your your taste buds just
feel like ah what was that you know
yeah I've been assaulted really late
yeah yeah look at your get a little you
okay I mean listen I'm no superhero
Henry I've done this a lot
but like you know whatever I'm human
these hot sauces they affect me I'm glad
you know that you and I can hit that
human note it's a shared struggle yeah
together yeah you know full of people
off-camera exactly you don't eat like on
a weekend but I fry a couple of eggs
with canola oil and my microwave half a
bag of brown rice I the two eggs cut
them up into strips throw them into the
Pyrex mug that I throw all this stuff
into a little soy sauce over it so it's
half a bag of rice two eggs so we'll
canola oil and some soy sauce and that's
like dinner is also lightweight some
people say oh he's frugal I'm just cheap
cheap cheap don't want to spend money
cuz in my line of work they finally
figured out he's got no talent
get him out of here and so one day it's
gonna be over and so I want to have save
some money you have to think about your
longevity rice and soy sauce and cups of
water
okay now this is I can taste the oil cuz
like the first second of it you taste
nothing which means it's like it's
coming through these have been it gets
more subtle and more but this is the
most here comes the way ah there it is
yeah this this hurts the phrase Punk has
become part of the modern lexicon but I
think that it's straight away from the
scene that you are a part of everything
from entrepreneurs to sports teams will
get described as punk rock so what I
want to do is bounce some things off of
you and I want to see if they fit the
punk mission statement as you see it or
if the two things don't even belong the
same also realize that that mission
statement as you say you ask a hundred
people who have some kind of idea of it
you'll get probably a hundred different
answers so I'm asking you so it'll be
the mission statement as you see it
Henry does that sound good yeah Bernie
Sanders is Bernie Sanders punk rock yes
in the idea sneaky of bringing truth to
power of cutting through the red tape
and the otherwise yield Beltway crap in
the political scheme you see how kind of
on his own he is and in a way that is
very punk rock what about air B&B can
disruptive tech companies be punk rock
sometimes they're described that way
when I think of tech companies
I just think ultimately there's so much
money somewhere one of those guys is
getting paid a whole lot of money and
other people are working for peanuts so
for me it's more corporate and could
never be punk rock anarchy yes Lady gaga
I think she's amazing and in our own way
very punk rock she writes her own
material her interviews are really
interesting she did this monologue and
she just talks out how much he hates
reality and I'm like thank you because
that's the job of an artist to me to
take reality like reality's reality like
his cubicles buses taxes and death let's
do something else like here's something
that can't happen
so let's write a song about it and look
you can internalize it and your mind
gets bigger so I think she's the real
thing big baller brand uh it doesn't
strike me much as punk rock two savvy
savvy marketing I think starting your
own brand is very DIY and so maybe in a
way it's punk rock I just think it's a
way for him to maybe do something that
surpasses whatever he's gonna do in
sports all right Henry
didn't
this is the last dab it's a tough one
and the reason we call it the last tab
is because it's tradition around here to
put a little extra on the last ah you
don't have to if you don't want to Henry
well how about this that one you eat and
you do swap
the old switcheroo I'll take your take
your dab and then you also I'll take the
recommended host damn I love it I love
it a little dab my own yeah a little dab
will do you
so what a run it's been Henry yes sir
it's been good food you enjoyed the
wings yeah yeah I did a lot yeah I like
chicken after we could get you lunch
yeah this this is intentional it kind of
come you came running up mhm that's what
it does it runs up on you have you ever
had a guest who just couldn't handle it
like a few wings in I've stared at the
other side of the table at some scary
things Henry but I will save this about
you very composed already put together
my lips hurt mm-hmm yeah no don't be
putting your fingers in your eyes all
right Henry have one more question for
you you know and senior talks and
watching your interviews I think what I
find most relatable about you is that
you're driven by this fear of inertia
and I actually feel a lot in common with
that you know sometimes I feel that I'm
at my best on I'm in the foxhole by
myself back up against the wall with a
chip on my shoulder is there hope for
people like us
or we just doomed to forever be on that
hamster wheel running in circles I'm
almost 60 in 56 so a few more years
something it's not old or young it's not
anything but it's not 20 and so after
many laps from the track in show
business
where you meet some people who are less
than honest and it's easy very easy to
get humiliated you get told no quite a
lot and you have big failures in public
where everyone's like you know they get
a photo of it whatever it is unless you
keep some amount of intensity and anger
with it whatever that is or you're like
I'm getting up today I'm going
what do you what are you angry at bring
it on whatever is in front of me I gotta
be mad at it to get through it I have
never been able to lose that what I have
done to displace some of that ambient
rage is work on my skills the sharper
the scalpel is I don't need to hack the
forest pal I can just take those two
trees down I don't want to relax because
I know myself
I'll just go foul
so I'd rather have the intensity than
nerves and the stress that comes with it
and perhaps a shortened lifespan from
always being inside Henry you came in
you cleared the board you dominated the
wings I know you doubted yourself but
not anymore watch that ball sail now
there's nothing left to do but give you
some plug time this camera this camera
or this camera let the people know you
have going on in your life I'm
struggling to get work and trying to get
by inside the guts of the Hollywood
machine I go fraud ish ins and I do the
thing big action big moments and I get
nothing
I get dang and then like I have to pay
double cuz I have to buy black
tablecloths I'm gonna beat my ass of
this and I get home I'm keeping this
[Music]
bad bad damn that feels better than my
father would bad bad come on give me one
hello hot ones fans it's Sean Evans new
outro same message if you like what just
saw throw us a bone maybe please it is
dog-eat-dog here on the YouTube streets
hit that subscribe button
knowing that you subscribed it is
seriously the only thing that gets me
out of bed in the morning thank you very
much hot ones fans I love you